así pues como bien decías el lenguaje
que aparece es algo menos estricto en
cuanto a las demandas hace mención a la
revisión de las n veces que son las
contribuciones determinadas a nivel
nacional es decir los planes de
reducción de emisiones que tienen que
presentar los países para alcanzar ese
objetivo del grado y medio centígrados
antes de finales de siglo en lugar de
urgir a los países a hacerlo les
solicita que lo hagan el año que viene
de hecho estas menciones son buenas
noticias porque de no mencionarlo para
el año que viene los países no tendrían
la obligación de revisar y mejorar ojalá
estas contribuciones a nivel nacional
hasta el año 2025 sin embargo recordemos
que para alcanzar el objetivo de parís
del famoso grado y medio antes de
finales del siglo deberíamos estar
recortando a la mitad nuestras emisiones
de aquí al 2030 y por ahora tal y como
están las cosas vamos encaminados hacia
un aumento de 2,4 grados así que la cosa
no pinta nada bien salvo que los países
realmente tomen acciones decisivas hay
buenas noticias en cuanto a que el
párrafo sobre combustibles fósiles y
subsidios sigue en pie sigue en el texto
pero añade un par de palabras que hay
que explicar básicamente mantiene la
petición de acelerar las acciones para
alejarse del carbón pero específica que
sea el carbón que siga emitiendo gases a
la atmósfera de manera no controlada es
decir que si se utilizan tecnologías
como por ejemplo de captura de carbono
este carbón se podría seguir utilizando
además está la parte de los subsidios
como mencionabas a los combustibles
fósiles añade el adjetivo de subsidios
ineficientes
esta palabra tiene un par de
consecuencias por un lado podría dejar
que los países sigan dando subsidios a
personas de bajos recursos para poder
acceder a estos combustibles fósiles
pero también podría ser la excusa
perfecta para que los países sigan
utilizando y haciendo uso de estos
subsidios y los expertos dicen que no
hay subsidios eficientes para
los combustibles fósiles y que más bien
esos subsidios deberían ir a energías
renovables sigue como recuerdo es la
primera vez que es la mención a
combustibles fósiles está en el texto
así que es una pequeña victoria